It was a little bit difficult to wrap your mind around it at first,...
...like this fridge that's outside.
How does that work?
But it does, it works.
My name is Viri from Mexico,...
...Chattanooga for the past four years...
...and I started the Chattanooga Community Fridge.
It is accessible 24 hours a day, seven days a week.
And the way that it works...
...is people come by and are able to get what they need from the fridge...
...and drop off what you can.
I'll clean it and stock it,...
...but it's your fridge, it's my fridge, everybody's fridge.
Thank you.
I grew up with a lot of food insecurity at home,...
...a lot of not knowing where we're going to get our next meal,...
...so this project, it's really close to my heart.
Access to food is a basic human right.
There is enough for everybody.
The fridge feeds a lot of people and builds a community of its own.
I hope that this can empower other people to take care of one another.
It's a really beautiful thing what a simple fridge can do.